un cierto mapeo en el plano ya tiene las
siguientes dos propiedades cada punto de
la recta igual a 3 x 2 cm apea en sí
mismo esto es importante se marcan en sí
mismo cualquier punto p que no está en
la recta de mapa a un nuevo punto p
prima de tal manera que la bisectriz
perpendicular del segmento pp prima es
la recta bien igual a 3 x menos 2 cuál
de las siguientes afirmaciones es
verdadera esta propiedad define una
reflexión o una rotación o una
traslación pausa el vídeo e intentar
resolverlo por tu cuenta bien vamos a
intentarlo y creo que para esto va a ser
muy bueno si lo visualizamos así que me
voy a dibujar por aquí un par de ejes
voy a decir que este es mi eje y por
aquí voy a dibujar al eje x perfecto
ahora la recta 3x menos 2 bueno se ve
algo así y luego nos dicen que en cada
punto de la recta y igual a 3 x 2 este
mapa en sí mismo lo que nos dicen es que
cualquier punto de esta recta después de
la transformación de mapa en sí mismo
por lo tanto se van a quedar justo aquí
así que esta es una buena clave para
saber que se trata de una reflexión
recuerda cuando haces una reflexión
reflejas a partir de una recta y por lo
tanto si un punto vive en esa recta se
mantendrá en ella al hacer la reflexión
sin embargo vamos a comprobar que en
efecto la segunda propiedad sea
consistente con una reflexión cualquier
punto p que no está en la recta tomamos
un punto p se mapa a un nuevo punto p
prima de tal manera que la bisectriz
perpendicular del segmento pp prima es
la recta que igual a 3 x menos dos por
lo tanto la recta 3 x 2 es la bisectriz
perpendicular entre el segmento penn y p
prima veamos
tengo que dibujar una recta que sea
perpendicular a esta algo más o menos
así y además debemos de tener la misma
longitud en los dos lados de la recta de
igual a 3x menos a 2 algo por aquí de
nuevo esto es consistente con la idea de
una reflexión que prima es equidistante
al otro lado de la recta donde se
encuentra p por lo tanto me siento
completamente seguro de que
una reflexión así que voy a seleccionar
esta opción perfecto y ahora hagamos
otro más y nos dicen un cierto mapeo en
el plano x james tiene las siguientes
dos propiedades el punto o sea en sí
mismo cualquier punto ven en el círculo
se concentró en un mapa a un nuevo punto
w en el círculo cm de tal manera que el
ángulo positivo que van de ven a w radio
cuál de las siguientes afirmaciones es
verdadera esta propiedad define una
reflexión o una rotación o una
traslación pausa el vídeo e intenta
resolverlo por tu cuenta
adelante
bien estamos hablando de un círculo me
concentro en on así que vamos a
dibujarlo por aquí voy a tener a mi
punto
ok el cual se llama p en sí mismo así
que ya cumplimos en esta propiedad ahora
cualquier punto v que esté en el círculo
se me concentro en homs se mapa a un
nuevo punto w también en el círculo cm
así que vamos a dibujar mi círculo tiene
centro en om y ahora tomemos por aquí a
un punto b no sé no se me ocurre pensar
en este de aquí este va a ser mi punto b
y ahora este punto pm se va a mapear a
un nuevo punto w en el círculo aquí
mismo de tal manera que el ángulo
positivo que van de vm ao w me de 137
grados
ok entonces vamos a fijarnos en el
segmento b que es justo este que tengo
aquí
bien entonces el ángulo que se forman
entre b&w en sentido positivo mide 130 y
7 grados así que aquí tenemos a w por lo
tanto si estamos pensando en ángulos y
estamos rotando puntos este punto
corresponde a este otro punto entonces
observar esencialmente rotamos este
punto 137 grados alrededor de om para
obtener w por lo que esta transformación
es claramente una rotación esta es la
respuesta correcta y tal vez al leer
esta anotación te parezca un poco
intimidante al menos lo es para mí pero
cuando empiezas a interpretar la
información y más cuando intentas
visualizarlo eso es importante
puedes darte cuenta que es simplemente
una rotación el punto v rotan 137 grados
para llegar al punto w
alrededor del punto o bien hagamos otro
ejemplo más
un cierto mapeo en el plano x siempre
tiene la siguiente propiedad cada
círculo con radio hrn y centro en el
punto x
semapa a un nuevo círculo o prima con
radio fm y centro en el punto x + 11 m 7
esto corresponde a una reflexión a una
rotación oa una traslación bueno ten
cuidado puedes estar tentado a pensar
que si hablamos de círculos y más aún
después de resolver el ejercicio pasado
se trata de una rotación pero ojo lo que
realmente está diciendo es que si
tenemos un círculo o con radio r y
centro en x que ok vamos a ponerlo
supongamos que este es mi centro es el
punto x coma bien y déjenme dibujar un
círculo con radio r
ahora lo vamos a mapear a un nuevo
círculo opriman con radio r con el mismo
radio esto es importante
tenemos el mismo radio y ahora el centro
está en x + 11 como yemen o 7 entonces
vamos a movernos al nuevo centro ok
estará como por aquí voy a decir que
este es el punto x + 11 como james menos
7 tenemos el mismo radio pero ahora mi
círculo se va a ver de la siguiente
manera va a ser un círculo más o menos
así ok
déjame poner que el radio es el mismo
entonces este es mi radio y también
toman el valor de r y ahora observa lo
único que hicimos fue trasladar el
centro 11 unidades hacia la derecha y 7
hacia abajo claramente es una traslación
así que vamos a seleccionarla
y hemos acabado hasta la próxima